tout au long de la semaine votre journal
de 13h évoquera un aspect de ce grand
moment qu'a connu la france en juillet
dernier aujourd'hui christophe duchiron
est jean-marc sûr ça nous propose de
nous remettre dans l'ambiance de la
folie bleus pour cela ils se sont
laissés emporter par la foule
ou champs elysées où les voitures
défilent et les passants presse le pas
parce qu'il fait froid ici même le 12
juillet nombreux sont ceux qui parade
est au spectacle de la foule tricolore
en ce moment c'est l'hiver
la france est championne du monde depuis
six mois
du monde en masse en bleu en blanc et en
rouge
en jeunes ou vieux en hommes et femmes
en costume ou en maillot en tout ce
qu'on veut c'était la foule des
supporters français
à chaque rencontre des bleus des
retrouvailles du terrain aux tribunes
fusent il gagne plus on les aime
toujours plus nombreux c'est la loi du
genre
un songe en hiver saint denis le stade
de france 80 sièges vides et de
supporters
didier porte et gildas riz le 12 juillet
france-brésil et les y était six mois
après ils y sont encore en ce moment
gilles et didier termine l'écriture d'un
livre sur la coupe du monde à base de
photos amateurs
aucun joueur la vedette aux spectateurs
la foule spectaculaire et colorée
clichés souvenirs
la preuve qu'il peut y avoir une
communion autour de quelque chose déjà
que les gens peuvent avant un centre
d'intérêt commun qu'il ya possibilité de
faire des activités justement de
mélanger les classes sociales qui est
qu'un échange vraiment qui c'est et
c'est pour ça que j'adore le football
du monde
chamia
saint denis marseille bordeaux lille ou
ailleurs la france est une immense place
des faits
à l'échelle du sport comme une
révolution française au lieu de rester
chez eux les français descendent dans la
rue
une envie soudaine de partager ensemble
un moment d'émotion au bonheur des âmes
la foule sentimentale salue la victoire
des lourds aux champs elysées le
triomphe les émouvants qu'un défilé
militaire larme à l'oeil
sourire aux lèvres de la pure folie
france bleu blanc rouge et black blanc
beur france tricolore multicolores que
reste-t-il de ces beaux jours crois pas
que ça soit la marque d'une espèce de
transformation qui ferait de toute la
france un ensemble harmonieux non
raciste et prix de fraternité et
d'égalité sociale
ça serait évidemment abusif des naïfs tu
dire cela mais il y a quelque chose dans
leur représentation de la société qui a
pu un instant se déplaçait légèrement et
comme référence je pense que ça existe
certains commentateurs n'hésitèrent pas
convoquer l'histoire pour parler de la
foux des champs elysées autant donc à la
libération dix équipes
peu importe les chiffres on pouvait
trouver la comparaison choquante
lundi 13 juillet foule des grands jours
hommage au grand homme
à voir ce monde n'y avait-il pas quand
même comme une libération une france
plurielle unique qui se reconnaissait
enfin comme tel il aura fallu dix corps
en coupe du monde pour en arriver là
au champs elysées ces lumières d'hiver
ces souvenirs de juillet
elle son arc de triomphe la plus belle
avenue des champions du monde
non
c'est vrai que c'est déjà des beaux
souvenirs demain suite de la série avec
le regard